the conventional wisdom about our world
today is that this is a time of terrible
decline and that's not surprising given
the bad news all around us from Isis to
inequality political dysfunction climate
change wrecks it and on and on but
here's the thing and this may sound a
little weird
I actually don't buy this gloomy
narrative and I don't think you should
either look it's not that I don't see
the problems I read the same headlines
that you do what I dispute is the
conclusion that so many people draw from
them namely that we're all screwed
because the problems are unsolvable and
our governments are useless now why do I
say this it's not like I'm particularly
optimistic by Nature
but something about the media's constant
doom mongering with its fixation on
problems and not on answers has always
really bugged me so a few years ago I
decided well I'm a journalist I should
see if I can do any better by going
around the world and actually asking
folks if and how they've tackled their
big economic and political challenges
and what I found astonished me it turns
out that there are remarkable signs of
progress out there often in the most
unexpected places
and they've convinced me that our great
global challenges may not be so
unsolvable after all not only are their
theoretical fixes those fixes have been
tried they've worked and they offer hope
for the rest of us I'm going to show you
what I mean by telling you about how
three of the countries I visited Canada
Indonesia and Mexico overcame three
supposedly impossible problems their
stories matter because they contain
tools the rest of us can use and not
just for those particular problems but
for many others too
when most people think about my homeland
Canada today if they think about
candidate at all they think cold they
think boring they think polite they
think we say sorry too much in our funny
accents and that's all true sorry but
Canada is also important because if it's
triumph over a problem currently tearing
many other countries apart immigration
consider Canada today is among the
world's most welcoming nations even
compared to other immigration friendly
countries its per capita immigration
rate is four times higher than France's
and its percentage of foreign-born
residents is double that of Sweden
meanwhile Canada admitted ten times more
Syrian refugees in the last year than
did the United States
and now Canada's taking even more and
yet if you ask Canadians what makes them
proudest of their country they rank
multiculturalism a dirty word in most
places second ahead of hockey hockey
in other words at a time when other
countries are now frantically building
new barriers to keep foreigners out
Canadians want even more of them in now
here's the really interesting part
Canada wasn't always like this
until the mid 1960s Canada followed an
explicitly racist immigration policy
they called it white Canada and as you
can see they were not just talking about
the snow so how did that Canada become
today's Canada well despite what my mom
and Ontario will tell you the answer had
nothing to do with virtue Canadians are
not inherently better than anyone else
the real explanation involves the man
who became Canada's leader in 1968
Pierre Trudeau who's also the father of
the current prime minister the thing to
know about that first Trudeau is that he
was very different from Canada's
previous leaders he was a French speaker
in a country long dominated by its
English elite he was an intellectual he
was even kind of groovy I mean seriously
the guy did yoga he hung out with the
Beatles and like all hipsters he could
be infuriating at times but he
nevertheless pulled off one of the most
progressive transformations any country
has ever seen
his formula I've learned involved two
parts first Canada throughout its old
race-based immigration rules and it
replaced them with new colorblind ones
that emphasized education experience and
language skills instead and what that
did was greatly increased the odds that
newcomers would contribute to the
economy then part two Trudeau created
the world's first policy of official
multiculturalism to promote integration
and the idea that diversity was the key
to Canada's identity now in the years
that followed Ottawa kept pushing this
message but at the same time ordinary
Canadians soon started to see the
economic the material benefits of
multiculturalism all around them and
these two influences soon come
mind to create the passionately
open-minded Canada of today let's now
turn to another country and an even
tougher problem Islamic extremism in
1998 the people of Indonesia took to the
streets and overthrew their longtime
dictator Suharto it was an amazing
moment but it was also a scary one with
250 million people Indonesia is the
largest muslim-majority country on earth
it's also hot huge and unruly made up of
17,000 Islands where people speak close
to a thousand languages now Suharto had
been a dictator and a nasty one but he'd
also been a pretty effective tyrant and
he'd always been careful to keep
religion out of politics so experts
feared that without him keeping a lid on
things the country would explode or
religious extremists would take over and
turn Indonesia into a tropical version
of Iran and that's just what seemed to
happen at first in the country's first
free elections in 1999 Islamist parties
scored 36 percent of the votes and the
islands burned as riots and terror
attacks killed thousands since then
however Indonesia has taken a surprising
turn while ordinary folks have grown
more pious on a personal level I saw a
lot more head scarves on a recent visit
than I would have a decade ago the
country's politics have moved in the
opposite direction Indonesia is now a
pretty decent democracy and yet it's
Islamist parties have steadily lost
support from a high of about 38% in 2004
down to 25% in 2014 as for terrorism
it's now extremely rare and while a few
Indonesians have recently joined Isis
their number is tiny far fewer in per
capita terms than the number of Belgians
try to think of one other Muslim
majority country that can say all those
same things in 2014 I went to Indonesia
to ask its current president a
soft-spoken technocrat named Joko Widodo
why is Indonesia thriving when so many
other Muslim states are dying well what
we realized he told me is that to deal
with extremism we needed to deal with
inequality first see Indonesia's
religious parties like similar parties
elsewhere had tended to focus on things
like reducing poverty and cutting
corruption so that's what jokowi and his
predecessors did to thereby stealing the
Islamists Thunder they also crack down
hard on terrorism but Indonesia's
Democrats have learned a key lesson from
the dark years of dictatorship namely
that repression only creates more
extremism so they wage their war with
extraordinary delicacy they used the
police instead of the army they only
detain suspects if they had enough
evidence they held public trials they
even sent liberal Imams into the jails
to persuade the jihadists that terrorism
is lammott and all of this paid off in
spectacular fashion creating the kind of
country that was unimaginable 20 years
ago so at this point my optimism should
I hope he's starting to make a bit more
sense
neither immigration nor Islamic
extremism are impossible to deal with
join me now on one last trip this time
to Mexico now of our three stories this
one probably surprised me the most since
as you all know the country is still
struggling with so many problems and yet
a few years ago Mexico did something
that many other countries from France to
India to the United States can still
only dream of it shattered the political
paralysis that had gripped it for years
to understand how we need to rewind to
the year 2000 when Mexico finally became
a democracy rather than use their new
freedoms to fight for reform mexico's
politicians use them to fight one
another Congress deadlocked and the
country's problems drugs poverty crime
corruption spun out of control things
got so bad that in 2008 the Pentagon
warned that Mexico risked collapse then
in 2012 this guy named Enrique Pena
Nieto somehow got himself elected
president
now this Pena hardly inspired much
confidence at first sure he was handsome
but he came from Mexico's corrupt old
ruling party the PRI and he was a
notorious womanizer
in fact he seemed like such a pretty boy
lightweight that women called him bum
bum sweetie
at campaign rallies and yet this same
bond bond soon surprised everyone by
hammering out a truce between the
country's three warring political
parties and over the next 18 months they
together passed an incredibly
comprehensive set of reforms they busted
open Mexico's smothering monopolies they
liberalized its rusting energy sector
they restructured its failing schools
and much more to appreciate the scale of
this accomplishment try to imagine the
US Congress passing immigration reform
campaign finance reform and banking
reform now try to imagine Congress doing
it all at the same time
that's what Mexico did not long ago I
met with Pena and asked how he'd managed
it all the president flashed me his
famous twinkly smile and told me that
the short answer was compromise Oh
compromise of course I pushed him for
details and the long answer that came
out was essentially compromise
compromise and more compromise see Pena
knew that he needed to build trust early
so he started talking to the opposition
just days after his election to ward off
pressure from special interests he kept
their meetings small and secret and many
of the participants later told me that
it was this intimacy plus a lot of
shared tequila that helped build
confidence so did the fact that all
decisions had to be unanimous and that
Pena even agreed to pass some of the
other party's priorities before his own
as Santiago Creole an opposition senator
put it to me look I'm not saying that
I'm special or that anyone is special
but that group that was special the
proof
when Pena was sworn in the pact held and
Mexico moved forward for the first time
in years way No
so now we've seen how these three
countries overcame three of their great
challenges and that's very nice for them
right but what good does it do the rest
of us well in the course of studying
these and a bunch of other success
stories like the way Rwanda pulled
itself back together after civil war or
Brazil has reduced inequality or South
Korea has kept its economy growing
faster and for longer than any other
country on earth I've noticed a few
common threads now before describing
them I need to add a caveat I realize of
course that all countries are unique so
you can't simply take what worked in one
port it to another and expect it to work
there too nor do specific solutions work
forever you've got to adapt them as
circumstances change that said by
stripping these stories to their essence
you absolutely can distill a few common
tools for problem solving that will work
in other countries and in boardrooms and
in all sorts of other contexts too
number one embrace the extreme in all
the stories we've just looked at
salvation came at a moment of
existential peril and that was no
coincidence take Canada when Trudeau
took office he faced two looming dangers
first though his vast under populated
country badly needed more bodies its
preferred source for white workers
Europe had just stopped exporting them
as it finally recovered from World War
two the other problem was that Canada's
long cold war between its French and
it's English communities had just become
a hot one Quebec was threatening to
secede and Canadians were actually
killing other Canadians over politics
now countries face crises all the time
right that's nothing special but
Trudeau's genius was to realize that
Canada's crises had swept away all the
hurdles that usually block reform Canada
had to open up it had no choice and it
had to rethink its identity again we've
had no choice and that gave Trudeau a
once-in-a-generation opportunity to
break
the old rules and right new ones and
like all our other heroes he was smart
enough to seize it number two there's
power and promiscuous thinking another
striking similarity among good problem
solvers is that they're all pragmatists
they'll steal the best answers from
wherever they find them and they don't
let details like party or ideology or
sentimentality get in their way as I
mentioned earlier Indonesia's Democrats
were clever enough to steal many of the
Islamists best campaign promises for
themselves they even invited some of the
radicals into their governing coalition
now that horrified a lot of secular
Indonesians but by forcing the radicals
to actually help govern it quickly
exposed the fact that they weren't any
good at the job and it got them mixed up
in all of the grubby compromises and
petty humiliations that are part of
everyday politics and that hurt their
image so badly that they've never
recovered number three please all of the
people some of the time I know I just
mentioned how crises can grant leaders
extraordinary freedoms and that's true
but problem-solving often requires more
than just boldness it takes showing
restraint to just when that's the last
thing you want to do take Trudeau when
he took office he could easily have put
his core constituency that is canada's
french community first he could have
pleased some of the people all of the
time and Pena could have used his power
to keep attacking the opposition as was
traditional in Mexico yet he chose to
embrace his enemies instead while
forcing his own party to compromise and
Trudeau pushed everyone to stop thinking
in tribal terms and to see
multiculturalism not language and not
skin color as what made them
quintessentially Canadian nobody got
everything they wanted but everyone got
just enough that the bargains held so at
this point you may be thinking ok
Tepperman if the fixers really are out
there like you keep insisting then why
aren't more countries already using them
it's not like they require special
powers to pull off I mean none of the
leaders we've just looked at were
superheroes they didn't accomplish
anything on their own and they all had
plenty of flaws take Indonesia's first
democratic president Abdul Rahman Wahid
this man was so powerfully uncharismatic
that he once fell asleep in the middle
of his own speech true story so what
this tells us is that the real obstacle
is not ability and it's not
circumstances it's something much
simpler making big changes involves
taking big risks and taking big risks is
scary overcoming that fear requires guts
and as you all know gutsy politicians
are painfully rare but that doesn't mean
we voters can't demand courage from our
political leaders I mean that's why we
put them in office in the first place
and given the state of the world today
there's really no other option the
answers are out there but now it's up to
us to elect more women and men brave
enough to find them to steal them and to
make them work thank you